now fdr during the depths of the great
depression
in his first inaugural address told the
country that we have nothing to fear
but fear itself those immortal words
were meant to instill
confidence not panic to convey strength
not weakness winston churchill during
the worst of the blitz on london
went on radio night after night to boost
the spirits of his people
as the nazis brutally tried to bomb
britain into submission
now both men understood that projecting
fear or worry onto a beleaguered people
is dangerous
in fact when a free people begin to
doubt their own survival
well that's when they need optimistic
unshakable leaders the most
falling into self-doubt or dwelling on
the worst aspects of our past or our
present
only breeds self-loathing defeatism
and despair and ultimately disaster
and this is precisely the mindset
today's democrats have adopted
joe biden and his media apparatchix have
become masters of anti-american
propaganda
they believe that we live in a wicked
racist country
a country that deserves suffering
punishment
and pain and what it did though
it also exposed what had not been paid
enough attention to
the underlying racism that was
institutionalized in the united states
still still exists has existed for 400
years
and and so what's happened is that
we end up in a circumstance like you had
here in kenosha
now justifying the riots while
condemning the violence
oh yeah that's really nice the obvious
question for biden that these
pseudo-journalists will not ask
is this sir how could a systematically
racist country elect an african-american
president
not once but twice has biden forgotten
his own resume
and here's another question what was joe
biden doing for the last 47 years
how many times has biden talked about
what a great country we have
and what a great people we are was that
all a lie or is he lying now
is he smearing this country in 250 years
of american history
and a cynical attempt to win minority
votes
well one thing's for sure his protectors
in the media won't try to find out
whatever's biden's motivation here
whatever it might be his words
are doing great harm his most ardent
supporters
now openly question whether america with
all its white privilege
will or even should survive a just
published new yorker piece titled
the american myth argues that the united
states
feels like it's unraveling the
foundation of our nation
has deepening cracks possibly too many
to repair anytime
soon or perhaps at all the attempt to
reckon with our unjust past
has produced more questions and new
divisions
about our future well the fact is
the hard left that's the hard life gave
up on america decades ago
they never forgave americans for
electing reagan
and disgusted with this country they
decided to
poison its future they took over the
universities
and began the slow but steady process of
indoctrinating our kids
to despise the united states turning
their minds against our history
our constitution and our traditions
now this sort of thing was going on when
i was in college but it's gotten
much worse since then over the last
35-40 years generations of young people
have been spoon-fed all manner of
anti-american poison
and these efforts well they've paid off
for the left
all over the blue states we see
ungrateful brats roaming the streets and
their antifa costumes
straight out of central casting burning
government buildings
and even terrorizing innocent americans
it's a stunning combination
of ignorance and rage the democrat party
that biden joined in the early 1970s
back then it still had some sense it
still believed in the rule of law it
believed that
illegal immigration was a problem heck
almost 40 years later barack obama went
to
great pains remember to distance himself
from the hateful anti-american rhetoric
of his mentor
jeremiah us of kkk wright
but now it's all changed donald trump
came along and democrats collectively
lost their minds and trump they'd met
their match
they met somebody who was unrepentantly
pro-america
but you have to understand i'm a
cheerleader for this country
never forget they're coming after me
because i'm fighting for you there's a
lot of truth in that one
now democrats could not risk him winning
again
so they threw in with the hate america
crowd hoping to ride the wave of civil
unrest after george floyd
to victory in november well that was
wicked
and it was selfish it was also a huge
political mistake
now two months into the chaos biden
scramble to come out and try to condemn
the violence but the damage is already
done
he's now tied his political fortunes to
those who've given up on america
he stopped trying to put forward any
serious proposals that
we know would make life really better
for most americans
because why would you want to make
things better for a bunch of racists
he certainly has no intention of
maintaining american power
because why would you want a racist
country to have any power
all he's left with in fact are the
scraps of manufactured scandals that the
media will toss
out from now until the election
well yesterday we debunked the atlantic
magazine smear that president trump
somehow criticized our troops
and today as if right on cue the press
moved right along
fulminating about bob woodward's new
book
today's big claim was that trump
allegedly downplayed the coronavirus in
public while
privately telling woodward that it was
much more deadly than the flu
well boden's biden's faux anger quickly
followed
he lied to the american people he
knowingly and willingly lied about the
threat it posed to the country
for months he knew how dangerous it was
now while this deadly disease ripped
through our nation he failed to do his
job on purpose
again this is nonsense the president
addressed this head-on today
it's just another political hit job but
whether it was woodward or anybody else
you cannot show a sense of panic or you
can have
bigger problems than you ever had before
and by the way he said as much at the
end of march we'll get that too
into that in a minute um dr fauci
normally treated his gospel by the
trump-hating media
he directly refuted the media's
anti-trump narrative
i didn't really see any discrepancies
between what he told us
and what we told him and what he
ultimately came out publicly and said
so did you get a sense that he was or
wasn't playing this down
no no no i didn't uh i didn't get any
sense that he was distorting anything
whoops suddenly fouchy's not quoted
anywhere now as for joe biden
he was the one who was downplaying the
virus he criticized trump's china travel
ban and was out campaigning
at events into march the reality is that
biden his team and his supporters
all of them in the press they've given
up on the country that you love
instead of respecting the actual data in
defending our constitutionally
guaranteed freedoms
team biden they want to lock america
down for months
of course there's an exception if you
want to riot
against trump you're okay don't think
about going to church though or having
any fun
talk about defeatists let alone stupid
and destructive
now by contrast president trump is an
informed
optimist he wants us to wash our hands
be smart if you want to wear a mask wear
a mask
and carry on of course bob woodward
would never put any of that in a book
we've been telling you since the
beginning of the year that the democrats
have no positive platform to offer they
don't believe that things are ever going
to get really better in the united
states
they never liked this country much to
begin with and now they've given up on
it
totally so the only way they convince
americans
to vote for biden is to accept less
expect a full bore effort over the next
two months
to demoralize you demoralize trump
voters
they want you to accept defeat before a
single vote is counted
and they're using big tech billionaires
to preset the narrative
there's nothing illegitimate about this
election taking additional days or even
weeks
to make sure that all the votes are
counted in fact that might be important
to make sure that this is a legitimate
um and fair election okay that's just
creepy
we somehow managed to vote in person
during every other
major american crisis so why not now
mark because trump's president that's
why the left is engaged
in an all-out effort to depress
and suppress the pro-trump vote while
meanwhile
you know swamping us with mail-in votes
so far these efforts have not worked
we're still
fighting for our country and the america
first populist coalition supporting
donald trump
we're optimistic and most americans are
just hard-working people they want to
live in safety and security
they haven't thrown in the towel and our
guarantee of life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
and they're not about to give up the
greatest country in history
because of a virus or rampaging radicals
and that's the angle